2023 was an important year for our
relations with our neighbors we saw many
developments on our enlargement policy
but we didn't know that we also maintain
very close relationship with other
European partners with Switzerland we
reached a common understanding on a
broad package of measures to take our
relationship forward on this basis I
look forward to the launch of formal
negotiations in
2024 we concluded negotiations on
Association agreement with Andora and
San Marino the agreement will enshrine
our privilege relationship and integrate
the two countries in the European single
Market I look forward to the signature
of our agreement in
2024 we also reached an agreement with
Iceland lonstein Norway on financial
mechanism for the European economic area
until
2028 the mechanism will help reduce the
economic and social disparities in the
European economic ARA and promote
stronger trade and economic
relations last but not least we turn the
new page in our relationship with the
United Kingdom in March this year we
agreed The Windsor framework we ensured
the protection of the rights of EU
citizens in the UK and enhanced our
cooperation in areas like research and
cyber
security 2023 brought very positive
achievements which I'm confident will
bear fruit in 2024 the this would not
have been possible without the work of
all the teams involved on the side of
our partners and in the European
commission I wish to all those involved
a welld deserved rest in the holiday
season and a Happy New Year in